بجهده وفخره بوظيفه نال عامل نظافه مغربي
شهره واسعه واحترام الجميع على مواقع
التواصل محفوظ العفاري يوثقوا عمله اليومي
ويعرض موهبته في مجال الغناء قائلا انه
يريد غرسه ثقافه العمل لدى الشباب ويقوم
محفوظ باعمال الانسانيه في مقاطع المصوره
وبهذا اصبح الشاب يحظى بنحو نصف اليوم
متابع على مختلف في صفحاته على وسائل
التواصل وسط الثناء على شجاعته وثقته في
نفسه
[موسيقى]
يعني امانه الناس على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي تحرص على التباهي واظهار اجمل
صوره رغم انه في الواقعه ما تكون ربما
حياتها الواقعيه انت تحرص على توثيق
يومياتك يوميات عملك وبكل فخر بالاول شو
اللي دفعك انك توفق اليوميه اول شيء انا
همم
عمل ومن ديالي وكذلك اللي كان دائما وسط
الرسائل بزاف لمنها انك همم يمكن انك تبدل
الحياه ديالك وخيم يمكن انا ما يكونش عندي
يكون هاملي وبسيط يمكن انك تطور الحياه
ديالك وتوصل بزاف ديال الاشياء
لتعترضك انت وزملاؤكم اثناء المهنه عمال
النظافه نحترمكم ونحبكم طيب محفوظ انت كيف
شفت الرسائل اللي تجيك من قبل الشباب في
كل المنطقه العربيه يعني تثني عن عملك
وتثني على شجرتك يعني الحمد لله قال الناس
يعني يمكن ان نكون انا اول نظافه يمكن
لك يوصل بزاف الفيديو مساج
[موسيقى]
حابين هيك نسمع منك اغنيه مغربيه لا احد
فنانين المغرب شو حابب تسمعنا بلكي تكون
فرصه لك اي جهه تتبناك اليوم على الهواء
مباشره الله
[موسيقى]
همم
قل له اصحابي واحبابي
اه ياني احياني راعياني
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اعذريني يا لامي واه لسان ودموعك باسبان
ابي
ان تخطيني تمسك قيمه كل صحابي وحبابي عمري
[موسيقى]